Від боротьби за назву до боротьби за церкву -
так експерти характеризують нову стадію  релігійних протистоянь в Україні.
Новий закон, ухвалений напередодні парламентом,
що зобов'язує  УПЦ МП перейменуватись і вказати
свою належність до Росії, в Московському Патріархаті
називають дискримінаційним і посяганням
на свободу віросповідання.
- Це абсолютно популістський закон, який ні про що,
тому що мова йде про якісь умовні релігійні організації,
у яких центр є у визнаній ВР країні агресором.
То, можливо, у нас є такі в Україні релігійні організації,
я в даному випадку скрінінг такий не проводив,
але УПЦ не має своїх релігійних центрів поза державою Україна.
Представники Московського патріархату запевняють:
їхня церква має лише духовний зв’язок з РПЦ,
але не юридичний. Релігієзнавець із цим не погоджується.
Якщо відкрити статут УПЦ МП, то в третьому
та п’ятому пунктах чітко вказано, що
українська православна церква є частиною
російської православної церкви, пояснює
релігієзнавець Ярослав Коцюба.  На його думку,
боротьба за назву дуже важлива,  бо це, по суті, боротьба за вірян.
- Як ви пам’ятаєте, коли почалась війна, то було досить популярним…
змінювали на цінниках магазинів і чітко вказували,
де виробляється  товар.
Сьогодні цей закон повторює цю ініціативу.
Віряни і громадяни України мають прав  знати,
справді, де виробляється цей духовний товар.
І дійсно дивна ситуація, що
самі представники  МП чомусь соромляться того,
що вони є абсолютно представниками російської православної церкви.
На думку експерта, цей закон жодним чином
не зачіпає релігійних прав і свобод вірян
московського патріархату, бо не втручається
в діяльність самої релігійної організації. Щоправда,
закон таки обмежує доступ священників
до частин Збройних Сил України.
В УПЦ МП є 4 місяці, щоб змінити назву.
Якщо цього не станеться, то законом передбачено
скасування статуту церкви, а відтак - і права
на діяльність в Україні. Втім, у церкві вже заявили,
що будуть боротись проти нового рішення
усіма законними методами.